Trascrizione: Claudia Rossi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
"Sei di coccio".
"Hai la schiena di vetro".
"Vai coi piedi di piombo".
La materia è radicata dentro di noi
molto più di quello che pensiamo.
Perché oltre ai sensi,
quelli che percepiamo tutti i giorni -
il primo gesto del bambino
è toccare lo spazio e gli oggetti -
c'è una materia simbolica
che portiamo dentro di noi.
Quella che ci fa dire
che è una personalità,
o persino un modo di fare.
Perché la materia
ha un significato molto profondo.
Anche l'etimologia della parola:
"Mater" è la madre,
in spagnolo la "madera",
il tronco che genera vita.
A questo proposito,
vi invito a guardare questo video.
Questa è una cellula di un embrione
che si sta moltiplicando, cresce;
e a mano a mano, queste cellule sanno
che diventeranno un organo,
in particolare quello del cuore.
A un certo punto, comincia a pulsare.
È sempre commovente, trovo.
E adesso, un secondo video.
Questo è un materiale
che viene chiamato "self-healing",
un materiale che si autoripara.
È un polimero molto particolare,
che viene utilizzato normalmente
per le tute degli astronauti,
in modo tale che possa
salvar loro la vita.
Nel momento in cui viene forato,
prima si autoripara e poi si autoguarisce.
Allora, la prima domanda di questa sera:
qual è quello vivo,
di questi due materiali,
e qual è quello inerte?
Forse, la prima cosa
che possiamo cominciare a capire
è che più andiamo nel micro,
più guardiamo dentro alla materia,
più invece che avere risposte,
forse si creano delle domande.
Siamo andati a scoprire
il bosone di Higgs,
cerchiamo di capire
le teorie del Big Bang.
In realtà, il mistero
della creazione della materia
sembra sempre più lontano
piuttosto che più vicino.
Il famoso fisico Richard Feynman
dice: "Everything tingles", tutto freme,
che indica proprio questa idea.
Senza voler tornare a una teoria atomista,
forse veramente siamo tutti parte
di uno stesso ambiente.
Non c'è una natura viva,
lontana da noi, idealizzata, perfetta,
alla quale dovremmo tornare
e noi siamo inadeguati
rispetto a questa natura.
Siamo tutti parte di uno stesso ambiente,
siamo una metamorfosi continua,
un po' come l'amato pescatore Glauco.
Allora questa è una prima riflessione
che vi chiederei di portare a casa,
come nuovi materialisti:
di non fermarsi alle apparenze,
di andare in profondità attraverso
anche gli strumenti che la scienza ci dà.
Rispetto alla profondità,
vi porto subito a farvi
una seconda domanda.
Quando uscirete stasera con il cellulare,
commenterete la serata,
e con un gesto molto semplice
manderete un messaggio.
Questo messaggio non sarà
per niente "leggero",
anzi sarà molto materico.
Prima di tutto, arriverà
in un data center,
un luogo fisico molto grande,
tendenzialmente in un posto freddo,
in Islanda per esempio,
perché i data center
hanno bisogno di molta energia
e sviluppano molto calore.
Quindi avrete un impatto
ambientale, in realtà,
pensando invece di essere
molto leggeri con il vostro gesto.
In secondo luogo,
se il messaggio non arriva
velocemente al vostro utente,
se non vedete quella piccola V
che arriva velocemente, vi darà fastidio.
Questo si chiama tempo di latenza,
e lo studiano gli ingegneri
sulla microelettronica.
Da cosa dipende?
Dipende dal materiale
col quale vengono fatti
tutti i vostri strumenti.
Più i materiali sono performanti,
più gli atomi vanno veloci,
più il tempo di latenza si riduce.
Ma che materiali sono?
Qui, un altro punto di domanda.
Sono materiali che vengono estratti
in siti lontani da noi,
spesso non sono più in Europa
anche per questioni ambientali:
sono dei metalli rari che vengono lavorati
da altri tipi di metalli.
Anche in questo caso,
ci troviamo davanti a un gesto
che sembra molto leggero,
ma in realtà è molto materico.
Ecco un'altra sollecitazione
di questa sera:
il digitale, il cloud
è una nuvola molto poco soffice,
anzi ha proprio la consistenza
della materia con la quale
sono realizzati i nostri oggetti,
dei luoghi dove li estraiamo;
ma anche, in fondo, di tutti gli spazi
che abbiamo intorno a noi.
Il digitale, comunque, non va demonizzato.
Stasera non voglio dirvi
che c'è questo confine:
anzi, era forse
la prima cosa che ho detto.
Piuttosto, penso che sia importante
capire come utilizzarlo,
quali sono gli strumenti che abbiamo oggi
per utilizzarlo al meglio.
Allora vi propongo di passare
attraverso i materiali,
quelli che lavoro nel mio laboratorio,
quelli con cui lavoriamo in architettura,
in particolare il legno.
Vi faccio questo esempio.
Quando pensiamo ad alcuni
materiali sostenibili,
pensiamo spesso al legno.
Immaginiamo, giustamente,
un materiale della tradizione,
molto bello, che ha una memoria.
Ma in realtà, oggi,
il legno, essendo molto richiesto,
sta crescendo nella richiesta,
quindi aumenta anche il prezzo.
Il che, alcune volte,
crea dei circoli molto poco virtuosi.
Vengono utilizzate
foreste non certificate,
non vengono ripiantati i materiali
che sono stati estratti,
o utilizzati, per la costruzione.
Quindi, in questo caso,
la cosa più importante forse
è proprio essere informati,
capire da dove vengono i materiali,
quali sono anche le filiere
che sono state utilizzate.
Questo come possiamo farlo?
Io penso, prima di tutto,
attraverso un nostro diritto,
cioè quello di sapere, di conoscere.
Come avrete visto, il filo conduttore
su cui vi voglio portare
è questa idea di consapevolezza.
Sul legno, per esempio, potrebbe essere
quello della tracciabilità.
La tracciabilità permette
di partire da un elemento
e tracciare tutto il percorso che ha fatto
fino ad arrivare all'oggetto, al prodotto,
allo spazio nel quale siamo.
Ma più che sulla tracciabilità,
vi invito a riflettere
sulla rintracciabilità,
quindi sulla possibilità
di tornare indietro sulla filiera,
avanti e indietro,
quindi in qualche maniera
di avere una conoscenza trasparente
di come lavorano i diversi processi,
di come sono stati realizzati.
Quando qualcosa è trasparente,
quando si è informati,
quello che si crea è la fiducia,
perché in qualche maniera si capisce
che l'informazione è chiara e strutturata,
ci dà una certa responsabilità.
Quindi, questa idea
di conoscere la materia,
dal micro al macro,
dall'estrazione delle risorse
alla tracciabilità,
che poi è una tracciabilità
non soltanto materica,
ma anche umana, sociale -
dove è stato prodotto questo materiale?
Ricorderete la tragedia di Karachi,
degli impiegati rimasti chiusi
all'interno dei capannoni.
È una tracciabilità che ci dà
una responsabilità molto, molto forte,
che in fondo non deve essere
neanche questa idea di rinuncia,
di dover in qualche maniera pensare
a dei materiali più poveri o più naturali,
quanto piuttosto conoscerli,
andare a fondo,
sapere come sono composti.
Forse, direi, quasi cambiare
lo sguardo sulla materia.
Peter Handke, uno dei miei
poeti preferiti, dice:
"Far seguire a un primo sguardo
una serie di primi sguardi"
Forse è questo, no?
È la cura, l'amore per la materia,
come la guardiamo.
Qui, appunto,  ho detto che di fatto
chi guarda il mondo in modo diverso
lo sta già trasformando,
è già un primo passo.
Allora, ecco il sottotitolo
del TED di oggi: la politica.
Io penso che l'interesse per la materia
potrà avere la forza
di parlare alle vostre idee,
potrà risvegliare la vostra progettualità.
In qualche maniera, inciderà
sulla vostra scala di valori.
Perché avrete una nuova consapevolezza:
autentica, responsabile, umana.
Si può fare politica con la materia
nel senso più nobile del termine,
perché quando la investiamo
della nostra intenzionalità, diventa viva:
non è più artificiale,
non è più qualcosa di inerte.
Quindi pensavo di congedarvi
con tre imperativi,
anche se non sono
molto prepotente di solito.
Il primo è: ripensate
alla vostra idea di materia.
Sceglietene una che vi piace:
ma consapevole, responsabile, sostenibile.
Diciamola, questa parola.
Il secondo: sentitevi parte
di un unico ambiente,
non c'è un confine
tra naturale e artificiale,
vivo e inerte, digitale e analogico.
Il terzo: siate attivisti materici,
perché non è vero che il gesto minimo
non è significativo,
che servono solo gesti eclatanti.
È l'abitudine, è la somma dei gesti minimi
che fa il gesto collettivo significante.
Perché, adesso vi lascio
col colpo di scena,
perché voi di che pasta siete fatti?
(Applausi)